i made a slight error in the electron
transport chain video and i just was so
i wanted to correct it in this one and
it's also an opportunity for me to
include a cup a little bit of
terminology that i forgot to include in
that video so when i described the
electron transport chain we remember
it's just you have some high energy
electrons and nadh and they get
transferred from one molecule to another
and as they get transferred they go into
lower energy states and they release
energy and then the final electron
acceptor was oxygen oxygen got reduced
right here but if you do if you look at
both sides of this equation the mistake
was i need two hydrogens if i have two
hydrogen on the right hand side in the
water i need two hydrogens on the left
hand side so there should be
there should be a two right there so
that was what i would consider to be a
minor mistake in the last video but this
also gives me a chance to introduce you
to some more terminology so this whole
process we know that this is called
oxidation right when one when nadh loses
a hydrogen remember oxidation is losing
formerly electrons but when it loses the
hydrogens it loses the opportunity to
hog that hydrogen's electrons so we this
whole process of the electron transport
chain is one molecule after another
getting oxidized until you have a final
electron acceptor in water so this is
obviously you could call this oxidation
you know just very generally and then
the second part
of the electron transport chain or maybe
this we shouldn't even call this part of
the electron transport chain the process
where the atp is actually formed the
adding of a of a phosphate group to
another molecule is called
phosphorylation
phosphorylation so the whole process of
creating atp by through the electron
transport chain remember the electron
transport chain releases energy that
creates this hydrogen gradient it pumps
the hydrogens into the outer to the
outer compartment and then that gradient
that gradient that hydra those hydrogens
that want to get back into the matrix
essentially go back through this atp
synthase this process of generating atp
this way is called oxidative
phosphorylation
oxidative
phosphorylation it's a good word to know
you might see it on on some standardized
tests or on your exams and it's called
this because you have an oxidative part
each of these each of these molecules
get oxidized in the electron transport
chain as they lose their hydrogens or as
they lose their electrons that creates a
hydrogen gradient
and then that through chemiosmosis
allows for phosphorylation so that's
another good word to know this the
transfer of these hydrogens these kind
of going through this membrane
selectively this membrane i mean you
know this atp synthase will allow just
any molecule to go through it it's
allowing these hydrogen protons to go
through it this process right here of
this hydrogen going through it is called
kimi
osmosis
chemiosmosis another good word to know
so the entire process called oxidative
phosphorylation they don't happen at the
same time oxidative generates the energy
because the energy to push the hydrogens
out and the phosphorylation happens as
the hydrogens experience chemiosmosis
and coback in and turn this little axle
and then push the atp or the adp and the
phosphate groups together
and then you can contrast that with
substrate
substrate phosphorylation since we're
since i'm in the mood to introduce you
to terminology substrate phosphorylation
this is actually what happens in when
the atp is produced directly in
glycolysis and the krebs cycle so this
is in glycolysis
and the krebs cycle and this is where
you have an enzyme
directly helping to produce the atp
without any type of chemiosmosis or
proton gradient so if you imagine if you
imagine an enzyme you know some blurb
some big protein blurb
and let's say it has the adp
so it has the adp there with its two
phosphate groups and then maybe it has
another phosphate group that attaches it
some other part of the enzyme this
enzyme facilitates without any kind of
chemiosmosis or oxidation it facilitates
probably in conjunction with other other
other energy releasing reactions that
may be occurring at other parts of the
on other parts of the enzyme so you know
maybe you have a you can imagine a
little spark right there and then that
twists the that twist that's this entire
enzyme this isn't exactly how it might
work but it's a good idea and then these
two things maybe get pushed together
when it's just an enzyme without any of
this chemiosmosis that's driven by
oxidation like we learned in the
electron transport chain we call this
substrate phosphorylation and the
substrates
are just the things that attach to the
enzyme and have something performed on
them so anyway hopefully you found this
little video mildly useful